hi my name is alex swarbrick i'm a lab
head from the garvin institute of
medical research
in sydney and it's my absolute pleasure
to be moderating this session
on spatial biology i want to start by
giving you an overview of the area
and some of the um kind of
justifications for why
we need to understand spatial biology
and then some of the technologies that
are coming through
that are enabling research in this area
so you know i think it's well accepted
now that solid tumors are
ecosystems of cells they are not simply
homogeneous
collections of neoplastic cells
we also know that there's great
homogeneity
sorry heterogeneity within the tumor
micro environment both within the
cancer cells themselves but within the
many
parenchymal and host cells that reside
within that tumor
and we know that those cells are not
simply passengers but play
really central roles in determining the
etiology of disease
right from its earliest stages through
to
governing treatment response metastatic
dissemination
and so on furthermore there's increasing
evidence that these cells are not simply
jumbled together or or admixed within
the tumor mass
rather that there is structure to this
so for instance
distance from a blood vessel determines
the oxygen tension within a tumor and so
that sets up gradients
of hypoxia and therefore gradients of
gene expression
growth factors and morphogens diffuse
over distances again setting up
gradients and so i think it's
while we need to understand the cell
types that comprise tumors we also need
to understand
exactly how they're arranged and then of
course there are other factors
providing spatial context and cues to
the tumor for instance the extracellular
matrix
which again can define domains and
borders
within tumors that are almost certainly
of significance
biologically so i think a great example
of
the kind of structures that we find
within solid tumors
are tertiary lymphoid structures and so
these are
um essentially aggregates of immune
cells
that resemble um lymphoid structures
like lymph nodes
in that they are immune cells coalescing
in an organized fashion and so typically
we have b cells
in the center here surrounded by t cells
and a number of other cell types like
stromal cells and
lymphatic endothelial vessels and we've
observed these in solid tumors for many
years but the significance of them to
solid tumor biology
is still really not very well understood
but
i think speaking to the potential
importance of
structure and morphology within tumors a
number of recent papers showed that
the presence of tertiary lymphoid
structures predicts
response to immunotherapy for instance
so what i'm showing you here
is a figure from a recent paper showing
that the
patients with the highest number of
tertiary lymphoid structures so the
red trace here had a substantially
better survival in response to
immunotherapy
than other patients so arguing that
there is a really
major functional significance to
understanding
the organization of cells within a tumor
so how do we how do we start to
understand this then we've we've used
methods for
a very long time that can provide us
with in
beautiful spatial resolution so h and e
staining of a paraffin embedded section
here on the left
for instance shows you this exquisite
spatial
organization and our ability to measure
that but of course this is extremely
low data content here we're essentially
measuring two parameters we can use
immunofluorescence for
for say three or four parameters but
still this is i'm a very shallow look
um at the actual biology of the cells
now on the right
in comparison new methods like single
cell rna sequencing are providing us
massive data density per cell but we
completely lose
the context we lose the uh understanding
of how those cells sit in space
so the challenge then is really how do
we put gene expression in its place how
can we
take combine the best of
systems that allow us to go very deep
into cellular phenotype and gene
expression
and genomics and epigenomics and so on
and put that into spatial context
well lucky for us there are a number of
solutions
emerging now in recent years to this
problem and i've
i've put examples of i guess four of the
most common
technologies here the first one is based
on
i guess an extension a quantitative
extension from existing methodologies so
multi-parameter immunofluorescence
so in the top left here we have a
section stained with multiple antibodies
on the vector system
there are other manifestations of this
technology like codex that uses barcode
and antibodies allowing you to increase
the
multiplicity of antibody density um
in the lower left is an example from the
read core platform which is a
commercialization of the physique
technology
this and other technologies like sigfish
essentially do in situ sequencing and so
this is a really
interesting novel solution to the
problem in the top right we have an
example of some data
from the 10x genomics vision platform
and so this is essentially
an array of capture probes across a
slide and it gives us
an array of um essentially
transcriptomes
and in the bottom right an example of
kind of a cartoon demonstrating how we
might use
the nanostream geomx platform which
allows us to do targeted
measurements so these are four really
kind of different approaches to the same
problem
and i think the reason we need so many
solutions is this is a complex space so
as you can imagine
in spatial analysis of a tumor we're
trying to solve multiple problems we
need
ultimately we need high resolution we
need
massive multiplexing we want to be able
to measure many many
proteins or the whole transcriptome for
instance we need it to be
sensitive so we need to be able to
measure not just highly abundant
molecules but also molecules that are
important to the biology of cells like
transcription factors
and finally we need these technologies
to work on
the kind of tissues that we typically
have access to and certainly in
translational
research that tissue is often formal and
fixed paraffin embedded
and so none of these platforms really
solve every one of these solutions and
so i think that's why we're very
fortunate to have
multiple solutions now um emerging
i'm going to spend a moment just
introducing the nanostring platform the
geomx dsp
which i think is a really fantastic
solution to
to this problem um and it works a little
differently to other platforms so
and given that we have a number of
presentations featuring it today i
thought i would
briefly introduce it so here i'm showing
you
a cartoon depicting the way that the
transcriptome assays work so on the left
here you can see
we have essentially a hybridization
probe binding to a target
mrna this probe is conjugated to a
barcoding oligo
via a uv cleavable linker so when you
hybridize these probes to your tissue
they bind to your to the tissue
and to the mrnas within it we can then
use
uv illumination to break the uv linker
in areas of interest
and then isolate those barcodes and
measure them
so this shows you roughly the workflow
here
starting at number one we stain slides
not only with a
with the library of these oligos but
also with antibodies that allow us to
get an immunofluorescent image to guide
where we uh do our studies we image the
slides select regions of interest we
then illuminate those regions of
interest
those barcodes are released they're
aspirated and then measured and in the
new
uh in the newest uh kits these
measurements are done through next
generation sequencing
and of course um as many of you will
heard from carl june's presentation this
technology can also be used by
conjugating barcodes
to antibodies so with that i'd like to
finish my introduction
welcome you all to this session on
spatial biology and i look forward to
five
really fascinating presentations
dr alex forbirk is an associate
professor of medicine
at university of new south wales sydney
nhmrc senior research fellow he's also
the co-head of the breast translational
oncology program
in the king home cancer center sydney
australia
alex will moderate the spatial biology
track where he will present his latest
work on spatial expression
in breast cancer and moderate the
following speakers
first will be arutha kula singh from
queensland
university of technology uh next will be
william wang from the broad institute
and masters general massachusetts
general hospital
then we'll have an ocean addiction from
advanced cylinder diagnostics
and then lastly we'll have kit furman
from now string technologies
so i'm really excited to present to you
some data from my lab
today this is all unpublished data and
using a combination of technologies to
try and understand
the tumor microenvironment of triple
negative breast cancer
so first my disclosures
okay so i i've already uh described to
you in my introduction
how we think of tumors as ecosystems and
so the approach that we take in my lab
to try to
tackle this problem and understand the
way these ecosystems function
is several fold the first is really that
we need to
understand the taxonomy of this
ecosystem this cellular
environment even though we have great
histological and morphological
definitions of cells
we have pretty shallow molecular
definitions of cells
and so really our first challenge is to
understand
the cells that are present which of them
are important what are the gene
expression
programs the signaling pathways and so
on that govern their behavior
and finally what's their expression of
therapeutic targets because we need to
know that if we aim to
change their behavior intervene
we then need to understand how these
cells are organized in space
the way that their organization
influences
their phenotype and then ultimately to
try to develop
novel treatment strategies based on this
information
i'm going to talk today quite a bit
about tumor infiltrating t
cells in triple negative breast cancer
now the reason is that
of all breast cancer molecular subtypes
triple negative breast cancer
is a has a very poor prognosis we still
lack a good collection of targeted
therapeutics for triple negative breast
cancer
in this disease t cell density is
prognostic
and in fact a proportion of women with
triple negative breast cancer do respond
to immune checkpoint therapy though this
is a relatively small proportion
and interestingly only in the context of
neoadjuvant treatment really
which is where treatment is given in the
into
women with a localized tumor in their
breast rather than metastatic disease
so we really want to understand more
about the way
anti-cancer immunity works in triple
negative breast cancer there's a bit of
signal here that suggests to us
that um there's more to find
and in trying to understand the way
anti-tumor immunity works in many solid
cancers often the model that people use
to think about
is is one where we uh compare patients
so we look at intra-patient
heterogeneity so in other words is this
tumor hot is it cold
is it an immune desert for example but
we want to understand more about
um the way that immunity works within a
tumor so
for instance do t cells exhibit
intra-tumor heterogeneity
is it enough to just characterize a
patient with a single measure or do we
need to really be looking in different
domains
across the tumor is that phenotype of t
cells influenced by the local tissue
context and then
could we potentially use this
information to develop more effective
immunotherapies
so to approach this problem the first
place we've started is to develop a
cellular atlas of early breast cancer
and here we're using
a very large collection of viably
cryopreserved
breast cancers that we've been
collecting for a number of years
across all the subtypes of disease these
tissues are dissociated
and every cell that we're able to
recover undergoes
single cell rna sequencing as well as a
suite of other methods including
sightseek
which i can elaborate more on in
question time if people are interested
and what this gives us then is a is a
really wonderful
taxonomy of the cells that are present
within a breast
tumor acknowledging of course that not
every technology captures every
cell so this is a very high level view
of the first snapshot
of about 30 cases here from this
early breast cancer cellular atlas and
you can see that
many of the cell types we know to be
present in
breast cancer are represented here and
when we
conduct really detailed annotation of
these cells we break this down
into a really detailed taxonomy and you
can see here
the major classes of epithelial immune
and stromal cells
breaking down into subsets of cell types
and ultimately
into states
from these cells
so i don't have time to talk about the
stromal or epithelial populations today
but
i want to talk briefly about the t cell
data as it
pertains to spatial profiling and so
here i'm showing you a umap clustering
of all the t
cells from our breast cancer atlas here
you can see that there are many diverse
phenotypes
present this also includes some innate
lymphoid cells
and k cells and so on but what's really
interesting is that we see a really
really wide diversity of phenotype of t
cells present within
breast cancers and in triple negative
breast cancers most of these states
interestingly
exist in every patient so it's not like
one patient has
type a and another patient has type b
most of these states are existing in
every one of the tumors that we observe
and while all of these states can be
detected in every subtype
interestingly there are three of them
that are enriched in triple negative
breast cancer and i've highlighted them
here on the right
the first one is a cell type with a
strong
activated interferon signature which is
associated with with effector t cells
we have a proliferating population here
cluster 11
marked by k-67 and many other
proliferation markers that's enriched in
triple negative breast cancers
and finally a population in cluster
eight here
with any many markers of t cell
exhaustion
and it's interesting because each these
three populations are really the
populations that we would associate with
a tumor that's got
some kind of anti-cancer t-cell activity
so again
arguing or starting to explain perhaps
why t
y triple negative breast cancer has some
response to immunotherapy
so the challenge then is how do we put
this in its place how do we take this
data and start to understand how much of
this diverse phenotype of t
cells within every tumor is actually
related to their location
and so we've been lucky enough to
collaborate with nanastring
on a project piloting a really
exciting new technology which is their
whole transcriptome
assay and so uh this experiment has been
a little bit
interrupted by by carbon 19 but um
so far we've managed to collect data
from six cases
so these are triple negative breast
cancer ffpe
blocks we've cut these are between two
and five years old we've then masked
them
with three different masks to identify
cancer cells t cells
and stromal populations and then we've
used
this ability of the gmx to choose
regions of interest
and we've selected 24 areas of
illumination where we've
used the uv light to capture gene
expression and these samples have been
hybridized with a whole transcriptome
panel so 18
000 probes against the very large
majority of the genes that we want to be
able to measure
so i'm really very exciting expansion
in the multiplexing capability of this
platform all on paraffin
so um this is the experimental design
we're using we're interested
very much as i mentioned in t cells and
in understanding the way that t
cells microenvironment affects their
their biology
so by using a com combination of the
composite immunofluorescence and the h e
stain we're able to select t
cells residing in the stroma nowhere
near cancer cells we can find t cells
in tertiary lymphoid structures we can
capture either them on their own or the
entire tertiary lymphoid structure
and we can also capture t cells adjacent
to cancer which interestingly we find in
in every one of these cases there are
always what appear to be pockets of
resistance so t
cells accumulating next to cancer cells
and so using the masking we're able to
collect not only the cd3 positive
fractions to get the t
cells we can also capture the adjacent
cancer cells or stromal cells
and so on so looking now
at our data from this this is now all um
generated through next generation
sequencing of these libraries
um so very high level view of the
sensitivity
of course you might be concerned that
we're working with paraffin here
and you you kind of wonder what kind of
sensitivity we're able to
achieve first i'm just showing you here
the
kind of areas of elimination that we've
collected this is the area
here on the on the x-axis and on the
y-axis is the number of nuclei so
there's a very nice
correlation between area of elimination
and the nuclei contained within it
as you can see of course the different
cell types have different sizes and cell
densities
so they form you know kind of different
correlations here but what's really
pleasing to us is that
we are detecting a really substantial
number of genes in each of each of these
areas of elimination
something a median of something like
seven and a half thousand genes per
aoi which is really very impressive
i think um as you can see as you'd
expect that there's a
there's a relationship between the
number of nuclei that we capture
and the number of genes that we detect
in each of those areas of elimination
so now using unsupervised cluster this
rna-seq data
well sorry not rna-seq data but gene
expression data from each of these areas
of elimination
this naturally falls into blocks of gene
expression here which is really nice
the first track in the legend on the um
heat map
here is the type of area of illumination
you can see that
the cancer cells in green they all
cluster together
the um primarily t cell and tls derived
populations cluster get together and
then the stromal cells close together so
that's nice
the the expected biology falls out here
and then
we have kind of patience uh stratified
within it
interestingly the the host cells within
patients are often very similar in their
gene expression features
whereas the cancer cell gene expression
features are unique to every patient and
you can see that in the blockiness
of that top left part of the heat map on
the left and this is something we
observed with single cell rna sequencing
as well that every patient's cancer
cells
are profoundly different in their
transcriptone whereas their
immune and stromal cells are very
similar
on the right you can see just a
different way of visualizing the data
using a disney projection here that you
can see that this the
generally the host cells clustered down
in the bottom left the cancer cells
cluster in the bottom right
and again you can see every patient is
different here
now one of the really nice things about
this data is that we can
while we know that every measurement
we're taking is a collection of cells
this is not single cells obviously
we can use methods like deconvolution to
start to understand
the contribution of different cell types
to each of these areas of illumination
and this is an area that
nanostring have been working in a lot
for a very long time
using their bulk gene expression assays
and now they can apply this to the geomx
system
and so what we can do now is use
published signatures of endothelial
cells fibroblasts
b cells and so on to predict the
proportion of cell types in each of each
of these aois and so again you can see
now that the the cancer cell regions
where we thought we were sampling cancer
cells are predicted to be composed
almost entirely of cancer cells
stromal regions of fibroblasts and so on
t cell regions primarily t cells and so
on
but we do also see some interesting
observations like b cells present
even within some of these um t-cell
enriched regions which i think is is
something interesting
that we want to follow up but i think
what's really powerful now is that
because we have matching single cell rna
sequencing data from each of these cases
we're able to use
our higher resolution taxonomy that i
showed you earlier
and asked can we use this to deconvolute
cellular proportions present
in each of these aois and we can and so
you can see here
some of these many populations that we
able to measure within breast cancers
using single cell rna sequencing data
can be detected very robustly within the
gmx data and so this is really nice we
can start to ask
look for relationships between cells and
you can already see
obviously relationships emerging for
example at the top there we see cd4 t
cells memory b cells and naive b cells
clustering very nicely and this is
probably
in part driven by their color currents
within tertiary lymphoid structures
as well as in other places now this data
is a little bit dense to look at so i
pulled out some examples here
that start to address more specifically
the questions we had around t cell
phenotype
so first just to show you that
deconvolution returns expected results
with our own single cell
data so these data sets appear to be
compatible our fibre blast signatures
are in
heavily enriched in the stromal
population and depleted in all the other
areas of elimination similarly
endothelial cells which we did not
target
are across any of these areas of
interest so this is a positive control
and a negative control
essentially when we start to look at t
cells we can see some expected results
here so
cd8 t cells are enriched at the
interface with cancer and are depleted
in either the stroma or in tertiary
lymphoid structures
so this might have been what we expected
that the cells interacting with cancer
cells proliferating
are primarily cd8 t cells which is
interesting whereas cd4 t cells are
depleted at the cancer interface but are
enriched
at tertiary lymphoid structures and we
certainly know that to be the case from
the literature
looking now more deeply at these subsets
of cd8 t cells which is really what we
want to try to understand
i pointed out to you some of these
populations earlier in our single cell
data
and what's really cool is that we can
now show that
it's at the cancer interface that we get
enrichment for these interferon positive
cd8 t cells for these cycling t cells
and so on
so again letting us link populations
identified from our single cell data and
showing
that these cells are actually the ones
in contact with cancer cells
furthermore looking at details of the
gene expression features
of these aois gives us further insights
into the state of these t
cells so when we look at gene expression
features now of the t
cells next to cancer in green or the t
cells in the stroma
or tls structures the purple and yellow
tracks on the left there you can see
that um
the t cells adjacent to cancer have
markers of maturation
so transcription factors like id two
ranks one we're able to to measure these
quite
robustly and these are arguing for um
t-cell maturation we can measure high
levels of the actual molecules that cd8
t cells use to kill
so granzyme and perforin for instance
and then obviously molecules associated
with activated interferon signaling like
irf1
so kind of stepping back now what this
really suggests to us is that
um subsets of t cells adjacent to tumor
cells are proliferative
and have all the signs that we might
expect of
activated t cells so elevated interferon
signature signatures proliferative
signatures
cytotoxic signatures and what's
interesting is that we find these in
every case so despite these
tumors growing these women presenting
with disease
there appear to be what you could call
pockets of resistance pockets of t cell
activation
occurring in these tumors but perhaps
these are too infrequent
to sustain sufficient anti-tumor
activity and so
really our thinking here is that we can
unders if we can understand more about
these pockets of resistance we might
understand how we can make them expand
in number and in scale okay i want to
finish up by showing you um
another vignette really this is a single
case i think but just demonstrate some
of our thinking
when we start to try to apply this
technology to understanding
neoplastic cell heterogeneity so the
cancer cells themselves
and the reason we're interested in this
of course is we know that
cancer heterogeneity is a poor
prognostic factor in many solid cancers
certainly we observe this quite
frequently in our single cell data sets
what i'm showing you on the left here is
single cell data from a triple negative
breast cancer and each of the
populations that i've circled
are actually cancer populations based on
marker gene expression and other
measures as you can see on the right
yet there's clearly quite substantial
gene expression heterogeneity between
these populations
so we are really interested to
understand how much of this is driven by
genomic differences between those
populations how much of that is driven
by
essentially the location of those
populations so i'm going to skip over
this slide in the interest of time
and so the experiment here is to take
one of these cases and interestingly we
often see
in cases with large heterogeneity at the
gene expression level we also find
morphological heterogeneity so here's an
interesting case where we see
on these h e stains here multiple
different morphologies as identified by
our
anatomical pathologist and so we
sampled these different morphologies
using the geomx
dsp and looked at gene expression
features here
and what i'm showing you on the right is
a heat map of the
most different largest gene expression
differences
between each of these regions and you
can see blocks of gene expression that
are unique and distinct
to each of these morphologies which is
really interesting and on the left i'm
showing you that
these different morphological regions
cluster based on
their their histomorphology so this is
quite interesting that the
morphologies associate with gene
expression features
digging into just a few kind of
signatures here relevant to the earlier
part of my presentation we can see for
instance
the different regions have altered
gene expression in pathways relating to
t cell
recognition so for example mhc class one
expression is very high
in this orange cluster here and
interestingly this population
actually resides at the edge of the
tumor in
right adjacent to some of those t cells
that we were talking about earlier
similarly this population also has high
interference signaling
linking it with the observation we made
in t cells earlier
we can also see in different populations
for example that
evidence for strong activation of irk
signaling and aktp3 kinase signaling so
this is now starting
to allow us to get evidence that indeed
some of this heterogeneity is driven
by spatial organization of these cells
and there are some really great tools
that we have available to us now through
this system that allow you to start to
map
morphology onto tissue and then layer
gene expression features on top of that
and i won't go into detail here but this
is these are really great tools that
allow us to visualize some of our data
to make this very complex
multi-dimensional data more
understandable so i'll just finish up by
summarizing
some of the findings here and you know
we're developing the cellular atlas of
localized breast cancer we're also
working in prostate cancer and other
diseases
and using that we've we've found a
number of novel cell types and states
that i didn't have time to talk about
today
but what we're really pleased about is
that this data seems to be compatible
with the gmx dsp
which can be used not only for discovery
work because this is a whole
transcriptome solution we're using here
but also to integrate with our single
cell data
and so these methods like deconvolution
methods can allow us to start to
drill down into the details of the cell
types residing within each of those
areas of elimination
using differential gene expression
analysis we've shown that
some of these t-cell phenotypes that we
see are
divergent based on their location within
a tumor and of course we need to
conduct these studies in much larger
cohorts of disease to strengthen these
findings and then to validate them
using other methodologies so i just want
to finish up by
acknowledging the many people who've
contributed to this work this is a
really large body of work both the
single cell
assays as well as the nanostring dsp
work here in particular kate sandra
dan and tony who've been instrumental in
the nanostring
dsp analysis we've worked with a number
of wonderful scientists at nanastring
and i really want to acknowledge their
contributions
our clinical collaborators of course
bring us give us not only access to
tissues but sandro
tool here is also a really fantastic
breast specialist pathologist
and has been very important in helping
us do the spatial studies
finally i'd like to acknowledge my
funding agencies the national breast
cancer foundation
and the national health medical research
council and if you're interested in our
work i'd love to connect with you please
find me on twitter
at dr alex smallbrick thank you
thank you alex warwick for that great
presentation uh we're going to follow up
with a few questions um
the first question i have for you is how
do you annotate
cell types with such confidence in your
single cell data
so that's an important question namely
how do we
get confidence in annotating different
cell types within
our single cell data we go about this in
a number of ways
firstly of course we use marker genes
and so there's obviously an established
literature on many of the marker genes
for different populations of cell types
however some of our work has revealed
deficiencies in that
one of the other tools that we i didn't
really have time to talk about in my
presentation that we
use a lot is sightseek and so i'm
showing you on the slide now
um just a little cartoon overview of the
way sightseek works
so here we have um barcoded antibodies
that are
and those barcodes are polyadenylated so
this is in some ways kind of similar to
the nanostring barcode antibody solution
except that we're staining cells in
suspension here rather than
on tissue and so these
barcoded antibodies bind to cells they
get encapsulated the polyadenylated
barcodes get captured along with
cellular mrnas and end up in your
sequencing library
and so like flow cytometry then you're
measuring the abundance of a
of a molecule on the surface of the cell
but instead of using fluorescence you're
using um sequencing of a barcode
and there are a lot of advantages to
using sightseek here firstly
because it's a facts like technology
it allows us to link back to facts-based
immunology and so
when we're trying to annotate
particularly immune cell populations
sightseek has been
really very valuable in giving us
confidence that the cell type that we
think it is from the rna sequencing data
also has cell surface markers that are
compatible with the existing knowledge
the other nice thing about sightseeing
is it's both sensitive but also can be
massively multiplexed and so we're using
libraries of
some somewhere around 150 antibodies
currently
here because they all just have a
different barcode so that's quite easy
to use and finally of course this is
really important to us
when we consider therapeutic targeting
of proteins
finally the other method that we use in
annotating cell types
is in signatures and transcriptional
signatures and so obviously when you
have single cell rna sequencing data
you can interrogate that data very
deeply and we can
predict the transcriptional drivers of
different cell populations so in some
scenarios that's also really valuable in
us
helping to identify distinct cell types
and how did you think about choosing the
areas of illumination on the geomix
platform
on your samples
so perhaps unlike other technologies
choosing the areas of illumination is
really one of the key
rate limiting or critical points in
the gumx workflow here really
you your whether your data addresses
your question
comes down to how effectively you can
identify and label those areas of
elimination and so this comes down
to a number of things i think probably
primarily the first is that you really
have to have an understanding of the
tissue that you're working with
you really you know we we probably spend
a couple of hours looking at every case
that we want to study and really
thinking about
the regions within that tissue that
we're interested in
we work very closely with an anatomical
pathologist that helps us
mark up that tissue and so on so i think
that's really the first thing that
people need to understand you don't
simply take a piece of tissue throw it
on the platform and expect to
get good data the second is really comes
down to how well your
masking works and so this this is really
based on your choice of antibodies that
you use
to to label different cell populations
of interest so you need to both
design a strategy that allows you to
cleanly identify the populations you
want
and you've got to make sure those are
quality reagents that you're able to use
as well
when would you choose to use geomics
over other technologies for your
research
so this question of which spatial
technology to
to choose um is obviously a really
interesting one there's no
um one answer for everybody's
application different technologies
really suit different spaces
um the geomx in my experience has a
number of really
valuable applications i think the one
that we're really excited about
is applying it to um
human specimens that are
either very small very precious
or poor quality for example but which
have
really important rich clinical
annotations so for instance
response to therapy data or survival
data associated with them
many of these cohorts are in paraffin if
these are metastatic cohorts often you
have very small pieces of tissue
that might not have been very well
sampled and it's going to be very
difficult
to work with them in most with most
technologies
what we're excited about is i think the
gmx is going to be really
great in in that setting at least
in understanding molecular features
of these very valuable clinical
specimens
and in your experience what are the
smallest areas of illumination that you
can use to ask meaningful questions
so this question of of how small your
your areas of illumination can be is
obviously one that's
uh everyone's interested to understand
look we ourselves haven't done any
benchmarking of this i know that
nanastring have and there's probably
some
published data on that what i can show
you though is one of the
panels that i showed earlier in my
presentation which plots essentially
number of genes detected versus
number of nuclei and so
you know you can see that obviously
there's a there's a relationship between
the number of nuclei
and the number of genes detected um but
what's really quite surprising
is that in certain certain areas of
illumination at least
whereas we're detecting you know above
median
so almost 8 000 genes in a sample it was
probably something like
20 or 30 cells and obviously this is
going to depend upon the transcriptional
activity of the cell type that you're
looking at
and other considerations like the
density of the cells and so on but
i can certainly say we're quite pleased
by this and this is an experiment we
plan to do which is essentially a
titration looking at
across different cell types what kind of
sensitivity can we achieve
based on different areas of illumination